soplará su vigésima Vela el año que
viene frontex es la agencia europea como
su nombre indica de control de las
fronteras exteriores de la Unión Europea
y el espacio schengen y para ello recoge
y analiza toda la información posible
sobre redes ilegales información que los
estados miembros pueden utilizar para
desmantelarlas frontex ayuda a los
países que se enfrentan a una fuerte
presión migratoria interviniendo por
ejemplo registrando e identificando a
los migrantes a su llegada en la lucha
contra la inmigración ilegal frontex
también coordina operaciones para
devolver a los inmigrantes irregulares a
sus países de origen desde su creación
en 2004 sus recursos se han reforzado
constantemente hoy la agencia cuenta con
2.000 empleados de 29 países a los que
hay que Añadir entre 1.200 y 1500
agentes desplegados sobre el terreno
para 2027 el objetivo es contar con un
contingente permanente de 10.000
personas con un presupuesto medio de 900
millones de euros que no es nada
excesivo dado el fuerte aumento de
efectivos según frontex en 2022
detectaron 330.000 entradas irregulares
en la Unión Europea Un aumento sin
precedentes del 64%. ese mismo año se
hizo público un informe de la agencia
Europea de lucha contra el fraude en el
que se denunciaba que los altos mandos
de la institución eran conocedores de
prácticas irregulares por parte de
algunos agentes y Estados miembros para
evitar la entrada de migrantes lo que
llevó a la dimisión del entonces jefe de
frontex en el documento se describen
casos de intimidación humillación acoso
abuso laboral y también habla de
devoluciones en caliente una práctica
ilegal en la Unión Europea se estima que
desde enero de 2020 a octubre de 2022
hubo 43.000 personas devueltas a
terceros países sin darles acceso a
procedimientos para solicitar